[Music]
all right welcome back to the Great Blue
State Red State debate uh with Governor
Gavin new governor Ronda santis again
thank you both for being here we're
going to take a little breathing room I
don't I don't mind the debate taking on
on a life of its own but let each other
breathe um I don't want to be the hall
monitor please don't turn me into that
anyway Let's uh let's look at the issue
of crime FBI numbers violent crime
nationally for each of your states keep
in mind this statistic shows what is the
combined rate of homicide rape robbery
aggravated assault the year
2022 on the national level the rate was
38.7 offenses per 100,000 people in
California meanwhile the rate was much
higher
499.00 th000 in Florida lower
28.9 offenses per 100,000 Governor Nome
let me start with you your numbers are
way higher than the national average
average how do you explain that when
Safety and Security I would argue is a
prerequisite for the pursuit of
happiness well I couldn't agree with you
more we're near 50-year lows down 55%
violent crimes in the state of
California from the 1990s and I want to
compare and contrast that with the issue
in Florida that you didn't mention and
that's the murder rate and let's broaden
it more broadly the issue is seven out
of the top those numbers were part of
the murder rate seven of the top 10
murder rates in the United States of
America are red states he has a 66%
higher gun death rate than the state of
California is a higher murder rate go to
places like Jacksonville go to places
like Orlando go to places like Tampa the
murder rates off the charts compar
compared to cities like San Francisco
and you know what even more egregiously
Sean and I think this is important the
American people deserve an answer from
you Ron you had one of the most worst
mass shootings in American history
Parkland 17 kids were gunned down lives
lost 17 others lives torn aunder you had
a a young Girl by the name of Jamie
Gutenberg whose father pleaded with you
to do something about it and you know
what you did they did the exact opposite
you made it easier for felons to get
guns without background checks without
any training these people pleaded with
your parents and the families to get
tough on gun safety and again you made
it easier for felons he said of you Ron
and I agree with him after after you
signed that concealed carry bill which
increases the likelihood Fred Guttenberg
said of more Jamies losing their lives
and more Parklands he called you weak
pathetic and small so with respect I
appreciate you're talking to police
officers in the state of California you
may want to spend a little bit more time
not on the Ohio Trail and other places
across this country you may spend a
little more time back in your home state
and address the murder and gun violence
in your own back so this is this is the
Slick politician you put up the rates he
has 500 per 100,000 Florida is 250 so
that's almost twice as much and he's
trying to spin that to say California's
doing good people are leaving California
in droves largely because Public Safety
has collapsed uh they have I mean you
you go when California's come to Florida
one of the things they'll say it's
almost like an aob Body Experience they
can go to the store get toothpaste off
the shelf pay for it and leave because
in a lot of these places in California
everything's under lock and key because
they' basically legalized retail theft
they have chosen in California to put
the interest of the criminals over
Public Safety uh they treat uh they're
easier on sex offenders they're easier
on all these crimes that are leading to
a collapse in the quality of life and if
you just walk around San Francisco uh
you will see and I think it's
interesting Gavin Newsome was mayor of
San Francisco so he took the San
Francisco model turned that into a
template for California's collapse now
the left wants to take the California
model and use that as a template for
America's collapse can let I govern no
no I got a
followv FL s Francisco is
126%
higher it's 84% questions it's 75%
higher what what let me also say what
are you talking about when jaing I know
you like by the way those are all easily
to lie anytime you're uncomfortable he
put you he put the statistics up there
your crime is you
doent you gun murder rate in your state
let the audence let the audience look at
the numbers the FBI numbers in the side
according to the gun control advocacy
group every town uh for gun safety okay
California has the most as you support I
know Governor restrictive gun laws in
the United States uh Florida has the
19th most restrictive yet if you look at
the year 2019 when each of you took
office uh California has had 21 mass
shootings Florida has had nine now that
is according to a USA Today AP
Northeastern uh University database uh
da data keep in mind a mass killing is
defined as the intentional killing of
four or more victims excluding the
deaths of unborn children and the
offenders by any means within a 24
period of time um I believe Governor Des
santis you get this first go ahead what
California wants to do is they want to
make it harder for law-abiding citizens
to defend themselves then they go easy
on the criminals who are perpetrating
the crime they don't stand up for the
men and women of law enforcement that's
why a lot of people have left the state
because they don't get the support from
the communities that they need and you
know Gavin told another lie he said we
made it easier for felons to do felons
are not allowed to possess Firearms
that's federal law that's been long back
that is AB lie that he's saying like
that that has nothing to do with buying
or purchasing a weapon so that's just a
lie another lie that's coming up but
here's the thing people are leaving
California in droves because he has
failed to stand up for Public Safety
they are on an ideological joy ride to
let people out of prison early to go
easy on them heck your buddy uh Gavin's
buddy in Los Angeles gasone he doesn't
even prosecute when you have I when I
was in Southern California for the
Reagan debate
uh a lot of the women tell me they have
to take off all their jewelry just to be
able to go shopping because otherwise
they're going to get mugged that is the
reality that people are facing in
California Gavin can try to put lipstick
on that pig but the fact of the matter
is he has failed the people of
California I love this guy talking about
backing the blue when you dangled
pardons for January 6 insurrectionists
85 of them that were literally were
charged with attacking law enforcement
you talk of big game about backing the
blue with all due respect to the crime
rate again he's not answering the fact
that he has a higher murder rate than
the state of California 66% higher gun
death rate than the state of California
and I can easily answer this point gun
safety saves lives I don't think it I
know it and the data bears that out in
the state of California California
proudly does lead in terms of Common
Sense gun safety Common Sense gun safety
saves lives you had the chance to do
something meaningful you had chance to
do something on behalf of those Parkland
families you did the exact opposite you
moved in the exact opposite direction
with all due respect look at your own
backyard Ron you're not mining your
backyard on this I will do that because
we have some of the we had two radical
left Soros District Attorneys like your
buddy gasone in La one in Tampa one in
Orlando they were endangering the public
and I removed them from their post Gavin
Newsome has not lifted a finger to rain
in gasone in La uh that that city has
collapsed that County's collapsed
because he is not enforcing the law
that's here's the this is what's
happening that California model in
Philadelphia seconds we got to go break
come on I mean you're running for
president United States you're talking
down the great state of California
you're talking down one of the Great
American cities Los Angeles that's
insulting and you're doing it because
you're trying to off escate the facts
that you have a higher murder rate in
the State of Florida and the state of
California we got lowest crime weights
we've had in 50 years we'll have more
with Governor DeSantis Governor Gavin
Nome on the other side hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else